What up, friends? Welcome to the second
installment of me taking requests to uh
come up with music to spend to, uh,
which I really need a much punchier name
for, but here we are. Um, so just to let
you all know, the theory here is that
you all get to request the songs and
music that I spin to in a flow video.
Uh, people like yourself leave me
suggestions and then my Patreon
supporters vote on those suggestions.
And uh unlike last uh video I did like
this, there is a clear winner and that
winner is wait for it, A Moment Apart by
Odessa. Now um I will confess I don't
know if I've ever listened to an Odessa
song. Uh I don't know. I I'm pretty sure
that they're an EDM artist, but I have
no idea what subgenre. Uh I have done no
prep for this other than checking the
runtime of this song. So, uh, let's go
ahead and get into
it. This time around, I'm going to be
spinning some Flammoia poi from Flow
Toyoys. And, uh, at the end of the
video, I will let you know, uh, what you
can do to go ahead and get a set of
these
yourselves. Let me make sure
that I have them at the right brightness
setting
here. Things I could have
done. Okay, cool. They're at the right
brightness
setting. And let me go ahead and stick
them on shuffle here so
that they'll automatically change modes
as I
spin. Cool. And now a moment apart by
[Music]
Odessa. Cool. Let me set the mic down
while this is playing.
[Music]
Just a little bit more volume.
[Applause]
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Heat
up here.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
[Applause]
Heat. Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat up here.
[Applause]
Oh, that was the song repeating. ing
even though I totally set my phone not
to do that. Whoops. Anyhow.
Um, so yeah, that was just off the top
of my head listening to the song for the
first time. I hope you all enjoyed that.
If uh you want to choose the song that I
flow to in this series of videos next,
you can leave me a comment down below
and let me know what song you'd like to
see me flow to. And if you'd like to be
one of those people that votes on the
song that I perform to next, sign up for
my Patreon at the $5 level. I will put
out a poll in a couple weeks for people
to vote on the song suggestions that
come in for this next round. Um,
and
if you dug these Flow Mojo poy from Flow
Toys, you can get a pair for yourself uh
and get a discount on them over at
flowtoys.com by using the promo code uh
drexfactor for 2025. That is drexfactor
for2025. Uh that'll get you a discount.
Helps out the channel so everybody
wins. But for right now, thank you for
tuning in for that. And speaking of
thank yous, uh, I owe thanks to the
friends of the channel. Big thanks to
Dark Monk, Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow
Toys, Pyroer Light Toys, and Ultraoy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible. Uh, you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links down in the description of
this video. And also, special thanks to
the non-b business friend of the channel
that is Becca Beckonin. Thank you so
very much for supporting my channel, my
work, and my mission. Uh, and also this
video and the videos on this channel
would not exist were it not for my
amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you. You all
rock. Uh, and if you'd like to support
the work that I do, here's three easy
ways to do that. First one is uh if you
want to get your name in the credits or
access to a whole host of other awesome
rewards, uh you can go check out my
Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorploy and sign up.
You can also, if you just want to do a
one-off donation, send me that via
either Venmo or PayPal. I will include
links to those down in the description
if you want to avoid signing up for
another subscription service. Believe
me, I get it. Uh but for right now,
thanks so much for watching. Uh, and if
you want to check out some more flow
videos that I've done, I'll go ahead and
include a link to a playlist of said
videos down in the description as well
as up on screen. Thank you for the
wonderful suggestions, everybody, and I
can't wait to see what songs you suggest
for me to flow out to next. For right
now, have a good one. Peace.